i think we've been programmed quite a
bit with our relationship with money and
we have a relationship with everything
known in our environment you have a
relationship a neurological network in
your brain for your parents for your
cell phone for your computer where you
live where you've lived in the past what
you're going to do tomorrow for the most
part the brain is a reflection of
everything that we know so along with
that is our relationship with money i
feel like i have a really good
relationship with money because i work
on having a really good relationship
with everything in my life did you
always have a good relationship i think
so i think so i've never really lived in
lack i just wasn't part of it even when
i went to college and i had to take out
student loans and stuff i always figured
out a way to always be a little bit
ahead of the curve
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that's holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn how to
attract things into your life enjoy
let's back up and just look at how
people
form beliefs because yes most beliefs
are created from past experiences right
so
uh children
uh when they're
uh in their early ages their brain waves
are very slow like their brain waves are
in alpha uh when they're like seven to
twelve they're in theta when they're
like two to six years old and and
they're in delta like when they're when
they're
you know
newborn to two years old and so
these brainwave states uh are states
that were really suggestible to
information so when we hear information
we believe it and we accept it we
believe it we surrender to it as if it's
the truth without analyzing it because
there's no analytical facilities yet
right the analytical mind starts around
12 or so 7-12 and that analytical mind
is actually what's creates a barrier
between the conscious mind and the
subconscious mind so 412 roughly
what we see
how we model our parents behavior what
they say to us all being programmed
subconsciously right and so so that's
really really important because
if you heard money is the root of all
evil
money is bad uh only certain people are
allowed to make money you have to work
hard to make money this is how you got
to do it and
that becomes the foundations
subconsciously like let's like
write recording
an audio file you just keep recording
that audio file it becomes a
subconscious program right
so a lot of people have a relationship
with money based on either what they've
been told or what they've experienced in
their outer environment right so
so then we gain information from our
environment and the stronger the emotion
we feel from experiences in our lives
the more altered we feel inside of us
the more the brain freezes a frame
and takes a picture and that snapshot is
called the memory so based on an emotion
based on emotion the emotion alters our
internal state so you're going along as
lewis feeling really good and all of a
sudden you have this trauma you have
this crisis you have this shock and all
of a sudden you have this dramatic
change in your internal state and your
senses get heightened
and then you freeze the frame and you
associate this internal state with
whatever it is that's causing it right
and that's how we create long-term
memories right so are our painful
memories more uh powerful or
beautiful memories more powerful uh
they're both equal okay and they're both
equal but but the problem is i think
most people
experience from more than negative
emotions right and those are negative
motions really are derived from the
hormones of stress right so the alarm
system the emergency system creates an
arousal
inwardly and that arousal saying there's
something dangerous in your outer
environment right and it could be a
person a circumstance an accident or
whatever
and that that change in emotional state
causes you to remember the event you
have to pay attention right you got to
stay really and narrow your focus on the
cause
so so think about people who have
relationships with money right from the
past all beliefs
are based on past experiences so you
have an experience where you lose money
you have an experience where
money is taken away from you have an
experience where you don't have enough
you're living in a place where there's
not enough money or a family that's not
enough money
then the emotion that most people are
living by in a moment-to-moment basis is
lack
like i'm in lack of having something
that i want okay
now there's nothing wrong with that
because the experience changes your
emotional state you freeze the frame you
take a picture the problem is
that's hardware so we think
neurologically within the circuits
of that past experience and we feel
chemically within the boundaries of that
emotion which would say for example be
lack right so now the person
before you go to the next thing what
happens to the body and the mind when it
is in an environment of lack
mentally or physically i'm in lack what
is what is the body of the mind saying
yes so the body is saying
i'm waiting
for some external event to occur
i win the lottery
i marry the right guy whatever it is
that you're waiting for that event to
occur
that experience produces an emotion
so the emotion then takes away the lack
and so when we play the game in
three-dimensional reality the creation
game in three-dimensional reality
we experience separation from everyone
or everything because our our senses
fool us into the illusion the
hallucination of separation i'm here and
you're there
i'm here and the door is over there so
i'm aware that i'm here at one point of
consciousness and the door is over there
another point of consciousness okay so
in order for me to get from here to the
door i gotta move my body and do
something through space i gotta do
something and everything in this
three-dimensional reality is gonna take
time and energy right so okay so then
here's here's louis right here
and then he says okay
i want this experience in my future and
your brain automatically predicts and
projects
how far in the future you think it's
going to take maybe it's a year five
years ten years thirty years oh my god
right because that's what it's going to
take to pay off that house right so now
one point of consciousness i'm here the
other point of consciousness is where
i'm placing my dreams so i mean separate
from that experience so then how do i
get to that experience in
three-dimensional reality you got to get
up and you got to do something you got
to go to work you got to drive to work
it takes energy you got to fill your car
with gas you got to eat food you got to
work you know all this stuff you gotta
sleep you gotta recover with your stress
and now people are
in a sense
waiting for the experience that's 10
years down the road or 30 years down the
road to happen
to take away the lack of them not having
it and unfortunately many times when the
experience finally occurs they can't
enjoy it because they're too exhausted
right
so then so you play the game you
you go to school
you study really hard or you study on
your own you develop some skills you
make the right choices you start
saving money you start learning from
your mistakes and then the game is how
many things can you accumulate and that
accumulation then you associate with
being wealthy or being abundant or being
successful right and some people get
really good at it right you can get
really good at that rule number two is
challenge yourself with lewis howes
there's a lot of people a lot smarter
than me i'll tell you that who are way
way broker than me there's a lot of
people that learn more have more
credentials more
skills more
degrees phds who are making a lot less
and i learned early on a mentor of mine
when i was extremely broke
about
11 12 years ago when i was broke
a mentor of mine
i was struggling and i was just like man
i don't know what else i'm doing i need
to do like i'm working hard and the
money's not coming in what do i do and
he said money comes due money comes to
you when you're ready for it and i was
like i'm really ready to make some money
right now i'm pretty broke like i could
use this money
and he just kept saying like money comes
to you and you're ready for it and there
are certain things we need to overcome
and certain actions we need to take in
order to be ready to receive the type of
money that we are then not going to blow
and mess up and spend
uh you know on stupid investments that
we lose it all
so if you get money when you're not
ready for it you'll you'll hoard it
you won't use it and multiply it you'll
spend it
and you'll lose it
um or you'll feel like
you'll just feel anxious because people
want it from you and you don't know how
to manage it so there's a process that
i've learned the hard way
um
that is okay money comes to you and
you're ready for it so when i know that
like okay if i really want to make more
money there are certain actions i need
to take
in order to come from that space i need
to focus on it i need to pay attention
to it i need to learn something that i
haven't learned around money i need to
overcome some type of emotional
uh blockage that i'm holding on to i
need to like look within you know can i
look myself in the mirror in the eyes
for 10 minutes
and love myself fully or is there
something i have yet to
address is there something i haven't
talked about that i'm afraid to talk
about am i blocking myself in intimate
relationships am i not being vulnerable
with family friends whatever it is am i
lying to myself if i look myself in the
mirror for 10 minutes do i feel
comfortable with me and if i don't
why
and lean into that that's phase one
another thing is you know the amount of
money you make is directly related to
the amount of value you add to others
and your ability to package position
and receive the money from the value
offer so someone might say well louis
you know teachers in america are
offering a lot of value they're teaching
these kids but they make whatever
uh you know 40 grand a year right i
don't know what the average salary is 50
000 a year right there
then they've been working for 10 years
and they make 50 000
is that fair
and it is fair because they haven't
learned how to package and position
their value is then you hear stories of
teachers who say okay
let me package and position the skills
that i have and create an online course
and and teach it a unique way and learn
marketing and learn how to package and
position so i can deliver the value and
receive more money
from this other skill so if we're not
learning how to position and package the
value we offer and we're just learning
learning learning
you have a lot of value to give because
you learn so much
but the thing that i'm hearing you say
is you you haven't learned how to
package a position and overcome that
that inner fear or doubt
of embarrassment or judgment and things
like that
this is a real fear because most of us
have this
i was at the point where i was so broke
that i was just like
i don't care if the world laughs at me i
just need to figure this out so i can
get off my sister's couch so i almost
had an advantage because i was so broke
and had nowhere else to go my back was
against the wall for a year and a half i
was just like
i'm already embarrassment to my family
to society like girls laugh at me
because i'm living on my sister's couch
like
i'm already being laughed at so i might
as well try something see if i can get
out of this position it's when life is
good
is when it's really hard
for most people it's when you're making
you know uh
800 120 000 a year for a you know a
number of years so you've got a steady
thing going on
you're like you're comfortable
that's when it's actually really hard
when there's a massive breakdown it's
easier because you're already in
breakdown like you're already like going
through so much you're like well let me
just take action and get out of this
it's when life is good
is when it's hard
because you're comfortable and you've
got to constantly put yourself in
uncomfortable situations in order to
grow
it's extremely challenging you're
educated you're smart you're attractive
you're talented you have good
friendships probably you are constantly
investing in learning
it's going to take you
putting yourself through a number of
challenges to get extremely
uncomfortable for you to want to really
start to grow exponentially and this is
why i always tell people
whatever the thing you're most afraid of
you want to create a 30 60 or 90 day
challenge every single day
putting yourself in the most
uncomfortable
scary situation to face that thing until
it becomes second nature
and i don't know what that thing is for
you
i don't know if that's you going live
every day on instagram and teaching what
you're learning if that's super scary to
you i don't know if it's you putting on
your own event i don't know if it's you
putting out a pot like i don't know we
all need to figure out like
okay what is the thing that i remember
been resisting doing
for a long time and me just saying that
it looks like that's something that
would be scary for you right likes
waiting just by you okay posing that
idea
so you need to think like is that the
thing that scares you the most is there
something else
is it interviewing people is it you
going live whatever it is you need to
think about the scariest thing for you
and you need to create a 30-day
challenge for yourself i can give it to
you but you've got to be the one to
accept it and take it and if it were me
i would say every day for 30 days you
need to go live for 10 minutes on
whatever is the biggest platform you
have and you need to teach what you're
learning you need to actually offer
value in a scary way rule number three
take action with dean graziosi the law
of attraction is it really the secret to
success and does it really work listen i
know for a fact that in my 20s when i
was fixing cars during the day i was
painting cars sucking fumes had
headaches every night i literally drove
a tow truck at night while
simultaneously i was getting into real
estate and the only way i could do is is
get no money down deals the worst deals
in town so i get done working on cars at
five or six eat and then go work on
houses until i know sometimes two
o'clock in the morning tired get up do
it again now during those times
i was envisioning a bigger future i was
hoping to be a millionaire someday i was
hoping to retire my mom who worked so
hard to make you know she worked like
three jobs to make 90 dollars a week and
i envisioned me having money i
envisioned the big house but there was a
part i was missing back then hey if you
don't already know who i am i'm dean
graziosi i'm a multiple new york times
best-selling author my new book
millionaire success have it's on fire
right now you probably see it everywhere
i've been able to start and scale 13
different companies my brands and my
companies have done hundreds of millions
of dollars in sales
in like 30 years of being an
entrepreneur and i love this topic the
law of attraction because there's so
many different opinions but in my
experience going from someone who didn't
go to college or coming from someone who
didn't go to college and used to work
blue collar hard hands dirty which
there's nothing wrong with it and
evolving to
big business doing hundreds of millions
of dollars touching the lives of people
all around the world multiple new york
times best-selling books all those great
things
i've really dialed in what i believe and
i think is the truth
about the law of attraction you see i
remember when the secret went viral was
at 8 10 maybe even 12 years ago i don't
even remember but the secret went viral
it's still a strong selling book and to
manifest to create vision boards to
envision and picture and meditate on
your bigger future is an absolute must i
teach it in my book it's a habit you
must have you must create a compelling
future for yourself if you focus on what
you don't want anymore which if you
focus on what your parents have if you
focus on what your friends family even
parents or loved ones tell you you
should do or listen to the naysayers or
listen to the negative news i'm sorry to
say that's the results you'll get what
you focus on
is what you get
but what happened with the secret it
stopped there it's not just about the
vision board it's not just about having
a compelling future that pulls you
towards a better bigger version of you
towards your next level towards living
your your full potential that's all
wonderful but the part that's missing is
action now you're saying oh dean you're
brilliant no i'm saying that because a
lot of people do miss it we create a
vision board we want to manifest we
focus on our bigger future but then we
go back to the same old habits we had
prior the same thinking that got you
here is not the same thinking that will
get you to where you want to go one of
my mentors said what the thinking the
the habits that got you out of egypt are
not the same habits that are going to
take you to the promised land
so the law of attraction it's a hot
topic books everybody's talking about it
and it's continues to go but i want to
tell you the definition of success is
taking that principle taking the law of
attraction but then how do you change
your habits how do you change your
routines and how do you stop doing the
things that don't move the needle in
your life that bring you down that cause
negativity that rob your confidence or
you just do out of a hypnotic rhythm
because everybody else used to you hang
around the negative people or you surf
online for hours and you wonder why your
business isn't working you have to quit
those things
open up space and start doing more of
the things that move the needle my buddy
tony robbins i love when he when he's on
stage he says listen you could sit in
your garden you could close your eyes
and meditate and say weeds don't grow
weeds don't grow weeds don't grow he
goes but when you open your eyes unless
you pull the weeds they will grow
same thing here manifested vision board
have a compelling future but get out
there and take action and a lot of times
it's as simple as throwing away the
things that don't move the needle in
your life stop doing this that doesn't
serve you doesn't serve god doesn't
serve making more money and then even
one step higher stop doing the things
other people taught you are the
definition of success stop spending
months wondering what your website
should look like or what color your logo
should be and start spending time on
marketing and sales and understanding
your avatar stop listening to the
naysayers in your life and dig in
following those who have already forged
the path in front of you listen there
are over 1700 new millionaires a day
being created in america think of that
number i get so many people say to me oh
the old days dean it was easier for me
to become a millionaire back in the day
no
this is the time social media the
internet the world becoming smaller has
literally opened up the opportunity for
so many people to have the chance to be
wealthy to to live to their full
potential to grab self education learn
on your own learn from those who are
already doing it and go faster and
quicker but it takes more than
manifestation you have to take action
and you have to change your habit also
to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number four live a life full
of appreciation with ken honda and once
you start appreciating money coming in
money going out you start appreciating
about other things so this uh arigato
and arigato out opens a door
to a new life which is full of
appreciation and i think we definitely
need that uh said appreciation melts
fear and anxiety
so if you start and if you keep
appreciating money coming and going out
you cannot worry about money at the same
time because a human mind can focus one
thing at the time so why has a very
interesting unique trick
uh of um
so like changing our
wire in their brain so once you start
appreciating
it's so funny because one of my students
said oh gee ken i forgot to worry about
money for a week
because you folk focus on appreciation
yeah i think this is
really powerful is is a very important
first step and when i think about my own
journey um
i won't say that i had a negative view
about money and if you had asked me to
describe what money was i probably would
have whoever i could think of that was
like glamorous and exciting and powerful
like that was my vision of money which
is why i was chasing it so hard
[Music]
ultimately coming to understand okay i'm
making more money than i've ever made
but i'm not happier than i've ever been
and the neurochemistry that i want to
feel like this is not taking me there
and so i began to what
what i began to do was change my
behavior so i changed my story about
money that what i flipped over into was
the only thing that matters is feeling
alive so i'm going to stop chasing money
i'm going to start thinking about value
and so i had a very negative connotation
around money and i just said look i'm
going to set that aside for now and i'm
just going to pursue
fulfillment i'm going to do things to
add value to people's lives i'm going to
work to improve myself that was a huge
part for me was always wanting to get
better myself
and what i found was i needed both i
needed a change of mindset i needed to
stop thinking money was going to solve
my problems but i also needed to change
my behaviors and ultimately i don't i no
one is ever going to think their way to
success
i think that
you're you
you have to think in a new way that is
advantageous but you have to act in a
new way that's advantageous so after you
know when you do the wax on wax off like
eventually we do find ourselves in a
karate tournament and we really do have
to fight yes so what does that look like
especially now in this crazy economy
that we're going through right now
let's get let's go to that next phase so
people are they're already arigato money
in arigato money out they've got the
futon for their wallet like they're in a
zen place like they're doing good
now like you retired at 29 not just
because you were thinking you retired at
29 because you ran businesses you got
very thoughtful about how to generate
money and save it
how should people be acting with their
money so we get now how they should be
thinking but how should they be acting
with their money thank you tom i think
it's a beautiful question and i i think
that's exactly what we need to learn
but because
once you start appreciating your life
shifts too for example one of the
readers on my book
she was a single mom
with a low paying job she was working as
a secretary and then she came to me and
she used to complain about
her low paying job but after reading my
book she
changed her attitude and she started
appreciating about life and boss and and
she realized that she didn't have a
college degree
but she got she was hired as a secretary
so that's a big reason to appreciate her
boss uh before she was office
complaining about him
and i think the feeling really probably
came across to uh his uh her boss and
she got a big raise in a few weeks
so once you start appreciating i i've
heard so many stories i can even write
few books on this uh once you start
appreciating your boss your clients
they appreciate you back so
in my 20s the reason why i i was
successful was i was little uh unique
in so many different different things
for example when i was doing accounting
consulting i divided my uh clients to
two groups one i do regular job the
other i always
bring something whenever i got to meet
them just a herb tea japanese tea like a
book or just not super expensive
so in six months i got so many referrals
from the the gift giving groups you know
i didn't ask for any clients right but
they gave me uh so many referrals and
the second you know a group uh not so
much so uh i
uh recommend everybody to start giving
more uh something a little extra nuts
like 30 more but something to to show
your appreciation and
uh it doesn't really matter if you're
florist or cleaners or
business lawyers or a dentist if you
start giving something you get more so
this is the law i think if you give more
you receive more and then there's one
more extra reason to appreciate about so
you you your life would shift so your
whole energy would be so different and
so content and i think people want to do
business with happier people you know
people don't want to go with people who
are very depressed
so the people with the radiance of
appreciation often attracts
more people and more opportunities so
this is not a new age or spiritual thing
it's a practice to to
um to appreciate more so what you
appreciate appreciates and i think it's
it's so simple so start appreciating
about money is the first step and then
start second step is start appreciating
what you have
and if you start sharing what you have i
call it gift
uh all of us have gifts i've written
probably like uh half of my books 20
books on how to discover your gifts and
monetize them
because uh we're born each of us is born
with a special gift and something to be
shared with this uh planet and if you
can find it and if you can uh improve it
and you can you can polish it and just
um share with a society i think
that translates into money so i wrote a
national bestseller
do what you love and make sure money
follows you so it's very important you
have to have both
so talk to me about that so the hearing
you i've heard you say that before that
you've written
that many books on um finding your gift
so one i'd like to know what that
process is i'm not a big believer and i
get this is um it'll be interesting to
see your take on this i'm not a big
believer that we're born with something
um
but i think that we can polish like
you're saying and really turn that into
something um how do people find it
and then how do they polish it
you know i taught
probably personally over hundreds of
thousands of people you know through
seminars and my coaching
i do a big event a few thousand people
at a time
and i do a lot of q a's so i have this
track record of how people found their
gifts and some people find them when
they're very young you know when you're
five or six or seven you
your neighbor finds out that you're very
good at chess and then he ends up being
being champion i've interviewed the
japanese champion once and uh some
geniuses are found that way but most of
us are not that way right we're not
olympic athletes or we're not superstars
so most of us are not born with only one
gift we were born with several mediocre
gifts like uh like i was i think i i had
a gift of speaking i had a gift of
teaching i had the gift of making jokes
i make i make old jokes all the time and
money could be very boring so and money
is there are so many funny stories
especially couples but anyway so you
know so there are many gifts small gifts
but you have to multiply them and then
you become one and only
so so i know where you're going with
that before we get to how you chain them
together
how do you find them because that what
you just said really resonates with me
you've got minor gifts mediocre gifts i
think was your exact phrase i love that
okay so you've got these mediocre things
inside of you how do you how do you find
them like i don't i don't know that
people and i know what you're the three
things that you chained together are and
that'll be really interesting to hear
you talk about that especially the third
one which you haven't mentioned yet um
how do people identify that and maybe
you walking us through how you found
your three will be super useful
so you know some people find it by
coincidence you know some people find
out that your your friend would say
hey ken you're good at speaking like
what you know because gifts are funny
thing it comes so naturally out of you
so you don't even notice it so even if
you're good at singing you're
speaking you're good at connecting
people that's another gift yeah i think
you have the special gift of connecting
people too
um so if you have even if you have so
many gifts you don't realize them unless
you you recognize them and
oftentimes uh i do um guide uh people to
find their gifts and in the process they
realize like oh gee all these years i've
i've known that i had the gift but i
never recognized it as a gift because
how do you guide people through that do
you have them ask themselves questions
yes or survey their friends some
questions that people can go through
literally a thousand yes so for example
one of the questions is like uh when uh
when you're small uh what what were the
nicknames and then the nicknames have
strong something uh by the way uh my
nickname was a teacher because i was
like teaching kids
other kids so like nicknames have
certain uh characteristics already or
like uh when your kids uh what were you
escorted
for when i was small my mother used to
say you know you talk too much don't
talk
that means i had the gift of talking
because i want to express myself so when
you're escorted about something that is
a gift
but you thought it's a negative it's
your
actually it's your flaws instead of
thinking it's a gift so there are
thousands of questions and then when you
just show light on that you realize wow
i just never thought that i had so many
gifts and then once you kind of like
recognize one by one by one
and then start sharing um without
thinking much you know you don't have to
be at this point you don't have to be
strategic about uh what what's going to
happen because it's well you know fun
things will come out you never know
i've seen so many fun uh miracles
happening to people's lives so you
discover certain gifts and then
once you realize the gifts will come out
on its own it's a so interesting organic
mechanism that because you're so
inspired
by
uh sharing your gifts because more you
share your people love it love it and
you know your listeners who love your
shows they're waiting for your shows
they'll be upset if you just get a sick
leave or something right
so that people give you energy so once
this cycle starts and you appreciate
them for supporting you
it grows and grows and grows
exponentially and then when that happens
you don't want to stop
and then at some level it will translate
into money rule number five eliminate
negative patterns with gabby bernstein
let's talk about manifesting
we are always manifesting we're always
attracting to us what we believe the
energy that we put out the thoughts that
we have so when we're in a story of
something that we do want we feel good
about it we put out an energy to the
world that says i'm a yes for that
and then the universe responds by
bringing it to us
but we're also putting out vibes and
stories and thoughts and beliefs for
things that we don't want and that
energy is attracting towards us
what we don't want there are four major
blocks to your manifesting power the
first one is the manic manifester this
is the person who has all the self-help
books next to their bed they're
repeating positive affirmations they're
meditating they're constantly looking at
a vision board they're telling all their
friends what they desire but they're
doing it with an energy that's needy and
frantic and that energy is what attracts
so while they think that they're doing
all the right things their energy and
their belief systems and their vibration
are not aligned with what they desire
and this is a major block to your
manifesting power the next block is the
pushy manifestor the pushy manifester
believes that if they're not over
working that nothing will happen for
them the harder i push the more i'll
achieve that is really a big block to
our manifesting power because when we're
in that pushy vibration and we're trying
to force something to happen we're not
receptive we're not in a place of
allowing and we are telling the universe
what our list is but we're not allowing
the universe to give to us what is of
the highest good
then there's the fearful manifesto fear
is an epidemic we are constantly plagued
by fear throughout our day the second
that we turn on the news the moment we
wake up in the morning the story goes on
repeat the loop of all the things that
are not working we have 60 000 thoughts
a day and the majority of them are the
same thought repeated over and over and
over again and all those fear-based
thoughts block us from our attracting
power so when we're stuck in fear we are
majorly blocking what we want by staying
stuck in the story of what we don't want
and the final block is the judgmental
manifesto
and this is the person who's comparing
themselves to others very jealous
talking negatively about other people in
some ways talking negatively to
themselves about themselves and that
judgment is a form of separation
when we're judging we're separating
ourselves from others but we're also
separating ourselves from our true
nature our true nature is a sense of
feeling interconnected and when we are
in a state of judgment we block that
connection
[Music]
how have these
different blocks held you back from
stepping into the person that you want
to be and attracting what you want into
your life let's start with addressing
the manic manifester your job right now
is to really just let go and allow you
can keep meditating and you can keep
putting your vision board together and
you can continue to affirm what you
desire but check in with your energy see
how that energy may be frantic and manic
and in those moments take a deep breath
release it you can even use the
affirmation i desire this now and i give
it over to the universe to present it to
me
let it go allow and surrender
to clear the block of the pushy
manifesto it's important to start to
accept that you are supported far beyond
your wildest imagination and when you
meditate and you relax and you tune in
through your stillness you can start to
feel a sense of a presence beyond your
own and that presence is the presence of
love within you and around you now if
you identify as a fearful manifesto
working through your fears a lot easier
than we think
the simple shift that begins this
healing of our fear is to just witness
it just look at it just call it by its
name
when we look at it witness it and call
it out we defuse it
and the final block is a judgmental
manifesto start to want for others what
you want for yourself
start to see in others that their
greatness is a reflection of your own it
doesn't matter which of these blocks is
the hottest for you at this time we all
are blocking our manifesting power on a
moment-to-moment basis so do not judge
yourself if you're noticing that these
patterns are blocking you take these
tips
apply one of these tools that i've given
you today and use it and practice it
regularly and you will see miraculous
changes in your life rule number six is
raise your vibration bob proctor when
you talk about money bob uh
you know i feel aligned with that too
the idea of
i i grew up in a mindset of where
i often thought that you know money was
the root of all evil or that money meant
someone had to do something negative to
get it or you always had just enough to
survive and i i find that we still see
that paradigm
existing in society but see when you
talk about money and even when i learned
with the monks where we really
understood the value of money you see it
as a as an energy source of service you
see that's what it is
yeah exactly you see it as an energy
source of service of helping of giving
of providing
tell us about that mental shift that's
made
because i feel that you're obviously a
teacher in the law of attraction and and
you know popularized and shared that
concept
how about when what are some of the
myths with the law of attraction when it
comes to money
because i find that there are a lot of
misuses or misapplications of the law of
attraction when it comes to money oh
listen when it comes to law of
attraction
it's almost synonymous with ignorance
hardly hardly anybody understands the
law of attraction
the uh the secret of course
uh you know
really blew up the law of attraction in
a big way caused a lot of people to
think about it but we didn't explain it
properly on that movie didn't get into
it in depth
and most people don't know how to get
into it in depth
attraction
um
is not a it's a secondary law it isn't a
primary law the primary law is the law
of vibration and the law of vibration
decrees that everything moves nothing
rests
we live in a notion of motion
circulation being one of the first laws
in the universe when stuff when
circulation stops death sets in
well
we
operate
on a frequency you do i do
and what we're really attempting to do
is raise the frequency that we're
operating on we want to operate on a
higher frequency all the time because
that's where
the real beauty of life is
well
this thing we're living in is a
molecular structure in a very high speed
of vibration
and the brain is an electronic switching
station that alters the vibration we're
in
well we operate on a frequency and the
only thing we can attract to us is that
which
is in resonance with us
so the reaction is actually attraction
it's like emerson said the law of cause
and effect was the law of laws
action reaction is the law of cause and
effect well
our thoughts
feelings and actions we send off
into the universe it's a vibration
the universe sends it back it responds
in like manner well the response of the
universe is the attraction
you can only attract to you what
vibrates in harmony with you
so if we see things coming into our life
that we don't like let's understand
what we don't like is in harmony with
something inside
so we better
try and understand what it was or what
it is
and then
get rid of it
attraction's a secondary law
and we've got to understand it is
very real
and you only attract to you what you're
in harmony with
when you want something that's on a
higher frequency you've got to operate
on that higher frequency because all the
thoughts and things that you require are
on that higher frequency
most people i say are living on an am
frequency trying to listen to fm music
it doesn't work
how do you know what vibration or
frequency level you're operating at
uh because
people often judge their
people judge their performance by their
productivity by their efficiency we're
not trained as you said with your
paradigm again going back to that we're
not trained to observe our frequency and
vibration and people are not sure so if
someone's listening and watching us
today how do they know what their
vibration or their frequency is how do
they diagnose that
well i think the only way to do it is by
the results you're getting
it'll tell you right make sense
see the results do tell the truth
they don't lie spirit manifests through
its polar opposite
always
we're spiritual beings
spirit flows to and through us and we'll
do anything for us whatever we ask it'll
give us
and we're asking in thought
so what we want to do is take a look
what have i been thinking take a look at
your results you'll know what you're
thinking
that's how you can tell the frequency
around you want to start
frequencies vibration vibrations feeling
when you say i feel bad what you're
really saying is i'm not in a very good
vibration
you say i feel particularly good you're
saying i'm in a pretty good vibration
conscious awareness of vibration is
referred to as feeling
so i think the way to really understand
the frequency and the vibrations you're
operating on is by the results you're
getting
yeah
if you're continually having problems in
all areas of your life
you're on the wrong you're in the wrong
vibration
you know very low level of vibration and
we can change it now i teach that in the
seminars i have
ways of illustrating and everything
and
it's important and as people get into it
they really like it see i think when you
hear the truth you'll know it
and
i came across i don't know it came to me
i guess
i was searching for a way how to explain
that
when you hear the truth you'll know it
well
there's music in this room right now
there's music in your room you may not
hear it but we know it's here
it's being broadcast it's in the room
and we don't hear it because our ears
are not operating on the frequency the
music is being broadcast on
but if we turned on a radio the radio
picks up on that frequency speeds it up
as a zippo way up on a higher frequency
and we can hear it
well
it's the receiver on the radio that
picks it up
sends it off on a higher level where you
hear it
when you hear the truth the truth
resonates with the essence of who you
are
and when it resonates it sets up that
vibration
it comes out on the conscious level as
knowing it is no
you just know that's right
yeah
when you hear the truth you'll know i
know it that's true
well that's true when you're reading
something
when a person says something to you
you hear it you just i know that's not
true
i know that is true it resonates with
the essence so we there is perfection
our spiritual dna is perfect
and when we hear the truth it's like
that's the receiver
and it clicks in you know and rule
number seven the last one before some
very special bonus clips is develop an
abundance mindset with marie forleo
something happened a few weeks ago that
made me realize that i have some weird
little rituals around money in fact the
next time i saw my team i actually asked
them i said does anyone else do this
thing and it sparked a really great
discussion now money is a super hot
button topic i don't think i have ever
met anyone
who doesn't have a complex and sometimes
tumultuous relationship with it myself
included
however i realized that over the years
some of my weird little money rituals
have actually made a huge positive
difference in how i feel and how i act
around money now a lot of these took
root when i was having a really hard
time financially when money terrified me
because
i was crazy in debt and any time i
opened my checkbook i was filled with so
much anxiety i could barely breathe and
i believe that these weird little money
habits have helped train my brain to
actually invite more of it in to
appreciate what i have and to give more
way so today i want to share two of my
weird little money rituals with you that
you might want to try out for yourself
weird money ritual number one
never say no to honest money so here's
what i mean by that the other day i was
walking home from a video shoot right
here in new york city and i have to say
i was pretty fried i was like toast my
head was down i had this huge bag on my
shoulder and i'm walking and i noticed a
penny now it didn't register at first
and i walked a few steps more and then i
said whoa wait
that was a penny back there so i turned
around and i went back and i picked it
up now i have to be honest part of me
feels like i should be embarrassed or
you know i'm picking up money off the
street is not pathetic
but then thank goodness the wiser part
of me said screw that that's money i'm
gonna pick it up
that's because i have a little pact with
myself i never say no to honest money
and that includes honest abe
i see you girl you're trying to pick me
up
i like it
i am not too good to pick up a penny or
a nickel or a dime or whatever off the
ground and whenever i notice money just
laying there i pick it up and i say
thank you
this is awesome
for me it's a reminder that the universe
is always there to give me whatever i
need and all it takes for me is to be
present to keep my eyes open and not be
too good for the little things for you
know the small blessings
i think there's also something really
humbling about honoring that loose
change because you know about a billion
people in this world live on less than a
dollar 25 a day so to just walk past
money no matter what the amount seems
incredibly arrogant and disrespectful
so you may want to try this one out for
yourself
never say no to honest money if you see
loose change scoop it up and say
thank you
weird money ritual number two keep your
money tight and right
meaning
i like to keep my physical money really
tidy and organized now you may have
heard me talk about how i used to
literally wash and iron my money back
when i was a kid
you heard of money laundering this was
the real deal now as an adult i no
longer do that but this habit is
something i probably picked up from all
my years working in restaurants
specifically as a bartender i never
crumple my money i always got to have
the bills facing in the same way i have
all my fives together my tens together
my ones together they are all organized
and neat and they lie flat in my wallet
you might think this sounds silly but
for me keeping my money tight and right
is a sign of reverence and respect
respect for myself for the money that
comes into my life and for the money
that flows out of my life i feel like
i'm being a good steward of it for the
time that it's with me
this one has zero embarrassment factor
since you get to do it in private and i
highly encourage you to give it a go
now these two money rituals are super
simple but i'd encourage you to try them
and at least see if they make a
difference in your life
i used to struggle a lot with
manifesting just the idea of it i would
watch videos on it and i didn't
understand what they were saying i
didn't i just didn't understand it
whether it's manifesting a lot of
attractions like what are they saying i
don't understand the words that are
coming out of your mouth and i would
rewind and watch again it's like i don't
get it i don't understand i don't i
don't understand and
it seemed
weird silly
not good enough for me to just sit on a
couch and think about money coming into
your wallet or
whatever it was that you're trying to
manifest you got to go do something that
in law of attraction you know action is
at the end of attraction like you got to
go off and and do the work if that's
been you have you been kind of
struggling with manifesting
or law of attraction you don't know how
it makes sense you rewind videos and it
feels too woo-woo for you
let me uh let me let me explain it from
a different perspective and and maybe
it'll help at least this is what's
helped me the first thing that i
realized is
very scientific is from the reticular
activating systems it's part of your
brain that decides what to pay attention
to and what to not pay attention to
there there are so many things that are
happening right now all around you that
you are not paying attention to most
things your brain filters out
your the job of the reticular activating
system you can go look it up ras
is to filter out most things and only
filter in the things that you should
care about so for example
um you know what color are your socks
today what color is your underwear today
you know looking down this street and
you know i didn't know that there was a
pine tree here what are you paying
attention to as you look out the window
you're looking at the tree you're
looking at the
the sign here you're looking at the
driveway you're looking to cuddle the
sky you're looking at the house you look
at the what material that might be
you're not looking at anything again
it's too blurry you're still looking at
my face you're looking at my car you're
looking at the color of the headrest
you're looking at my outfit like what
are you paying attention to most things
you're ignoring
because there's no possible way to pay
attention to everything potentially the
dog just anna
hello good girl
right we're ignoring most things because
it wouldn't serve you that's just
impossible be information overload if
you feel like you're overloaded already
just imagine if you took in absolutely
everything so your eyes are bringing it
in and your brain is filtering out most
of it so what does your brain actually
pay attention to well the reticular
activating system
will choose to say okay you've set an
intention right i want to pay attention
to x and now all of a sudden you're
going to see that more often i i'm i
just bought a house so in that process
we started paying attention a lot more
to houses so one of the things i noticed
was the for sale sign here where i may
have not noticed that as much
in the past but because thinking house
boom now i'm paying attention to the for
sale sign
you ever notice when you buy a car you
start seeing that car everywhere right
you're even thinking about buying a car
you're thinking about buying an x
you start seeing it on the street
more often
why that's your reticular activating
system basically saying
i want to pay attention to those things
so that car was still around right i
mean i i got this car we've got a
porsche
and now i see porsches more often those
porsches still existed they were they
were already there i just didn't notice
them before and now i notice them
because i have one right um
so whatever it is that you want
whatever it is that you're sending
intention towards it's not just sit on
your couch and meditate and imagine
money coming into your wallet or a new
car or new house or business growth or
you speaking on stage or whatever your
goals are right it's not just sitting on
it and visualizing it but it's noticing
it and the elements of it in your
environment that when you start thinking
about it
right we are we consistently think about
when you start thinking about it you'll
start seeing opportunities around you
that were already there
you just filtered it out because you
didn't see how it connected
now your brain's starting to make those
connections does that make sense
reticular activating system you're
ignoring most things but when you set
intention on the thing that matters to
you you'll start seeing it in your
environment and opportunities for that
to happen a lot more often so that's
step number one reticular activating
system it's the science number two is to
trust your intuition more one of the
things that really helped me back early
on in my career was i
judged myself too harshly for the ideas
that i came up with
and as soon as i came up with an idea i
was like oh you can't do that or i had
the perfect plan before i would ever
take any kind of action on it and you
know just later realize that
you can never plan all the way out
there's no way you know if you wait to
have the perfect plan by the time you
start actually executing the plan is
is dead it's over
and so you have to trust in your ideas
and so the thing that
really helped me is
i believe that great ideas flow through
me
believe that great ideas flow through
you this is how you shortcut them your
brain that's designed to keep you safe
that's how you shortcut the brain out of
the equation
you came up with an idea as long as it's
in
you're in a positive state of mind
you're trying to serve right it's not i
want to i want to go
you're in a jealous rage or you're angry
don't trust your ideas then
but when when you're positive and
optimistic and bold and courageous and
an idea comes to you trust that that's
the right idea for you just trust it
it's around it and then go do something
about it where normally what we do is we
overthink and we over plan and we over
prepare and then we lose the momentum
and then the next day and the next week
or the next month it's gone it's over
it's like i can't do that no that was
actually a great idea for you and it's
happened enough to me
uh
where those things have worked out
where i come up with an idea
and it doesn't make any sense
logically
but
i just decide to listen to it and do
something on it and it leads to
something amazing
the amount of times that that's happened
is
pretty overwhelming
and so when you have enough repetition
for me i had to see it you know i had to
see it enough times come up because i
wouldn't just believe it on faith i had
to see it happen enough times and you
could test it yourself what ideas in
your head what big idea that you want to
do even a small idea what's what's
flowing through your head when you're in
a positive state you know put on a happy
song
move around a little bit and then notice
your thoughts and where it's going and
what you want to create or who you want
to reach out to what you want to do like
what what thought comes to mind after
you're moving around and having some
positive energy that's probably the
right thing for you and just test it out
by doing something about it and maybe
that's a business idea maybe that's an
email you need to send maybe that's a
friend you need to reach out to
maybe that's an act of kindness that you
need to do whatever the thing is that
pops into your mind
trust those ideas and and you could be a
scientist like i'm i like data and i
like science and i like just i like
proving things
maybe i'm a skeptic i don't know but
in running those experiments i i proved
to myself that yeah great ideas
do flow through me and so the next time
i have a great idea i'm gonna go
and take action on it
so number one reticular activating
system
it's already in your environment you're
just ignoring it but if you put
attention towards it you start seeing it
like you notice a new car
when you buy your new car you see that
car everywhere and then number two is
trust that good ideas flow through you
number three is the one that i'm working
on that i'm i'm having
the hardest time with and i i
believe it and i'm trying to
i'm in the process of getting better at
it is
when you're thinking about creating
something to talk to yourself in the
present moment
and this is something that
a lot of the manifestation a lot of
attraction people talk about but also
people like grant cardone talk about it
uh that it's it's not just
the people who would associate with it
but other people have had a lot of
success where you're talking about
whatever thing is that you want that
it's that it's already happened that
it's not going to happen in the future
but that it's already happened you know
if your goal is to speak on stage then
you're
visualizing and you're telling yourself
i i am
i am on stage i am speaking to
i am speaking to a million people or
that's that's that's a giant stadium
i am speaking to 70 000 people you know
i am i am the author of a best-selling
book uh i am like whatever your goal is
and
what i think the point of that is
is yes one to see yourself accomplishing
big things
uh two to not have a b so far away that
it lets you off the hook for taking
action but i think most importantly is
for you to feel what it feels like to be
that
and the more you feel like it feels like
to be that the more it actually becomes
true
if your goal is to speak on stage in
front of 5 000 people
and you actually
feel like you're doing it you can
visualize yourself being on stage and
doing it
the goal i think i'm still working
through this so one and two i've got
down three is my progress and my journey
so sharing with you
if you feel like you're doing it if you
are on stage and there's 5 000 people
clapping for you and cheering you you
just gave the best speech you know of
your life so far
and you feel what it feels like to walk
off that stage and
what a gift that you gave people
that the more comfortable you get with
that feeling
the more it's gonna be you
and the more that's gonna show up does
that make sense so whatever it is that
you are trying to accomplish
whoever it is that you're trying to be
whatever your big goals are
that
you imagine yourself already having done
it
and this is probably not something that
i would tell other people you know like
oh yeah i'm a i'm uh you know i'm a
speaker in front of 70 000 people
because
because i haven't spoken at a stadium
that big
but
to yourself at least
to say it to see it to feel it to do it
if you're trying to heal yourself like
okay i am i am healthy
but look i've got i've got a belly or
i've got a you know whatever i'm i'm i
am healthy i am healthy and and
visualizing yourself being healthy
because you want the feeling of what it
feels like to be healthy and the more
you feel like you are healthy and you
capture that feeling the more frequently
you're in there the more likely it's
going to show up
so that's probably not the most
articulate way to share it and i'm still
working my way through it as well so as
i keep getting better and keep learning
i'll keep sharing with you but
i used to think like
manifestation law of attraction was way
out there stuff that that i judged and
that i didn't understand and that didn't
make any sense like just go off and take
action guys
and
with time and experience and exposure
and practice
um
using the reticular activating system to
notice things around me
by trusting that great ideas flow
through me and following through and
building momentum
and by
talking to myself in the present moment
as if
i am that person that i want to become
so i can capture that feeling and know
what it feels like to be that person
i've shifted and seen some pretty
amazing results in my life and business
and i hope it can work for you too
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because
you are awesome if you want to reprogram
your mind for success check the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe and see you
there i mean the mind is like a computer
program and the fact that it's on a
negative loop is because we programmed
it on a negative loop but you know we
could have been influenced when we're
children and things like that one of the
things that the mind loves is love's
repetition